you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network
[Music]
what that was my son
what was that intro you just said the
name of the show it's yeah I said you
listens dollop on the other things
comedy networking when I played the song
you said yes well let's do the intro
that was the intro no you say you know
you listen to dog this is a biweekly by
the coastal I do that before the music
it certainly has happened by now you're
listening to the dollop on the all
things comedy and network this is a
bi-weekly American history podcast each
week I Dave Anthony read a story from
American history to my acquaintances
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about now you
didn't mean are you happy yeah it's
better it's still shoddy you suck we
don't even hear the intro again they
sound [ __ ] stop playing the intro
again
nobody wants [ __ ] is this an elective
you're trying to do are you trying to
teach some kind of lesson
[Music]
that is what is anything well what's
gonna happen is I'm just gonna edit out
the first part and now you'll sound like
an [ __ ] but that's unfair that's
that's that's what's gonna happen and
that's what you should have understood
from the beginning of that that's unfair
why is it unfair because we don't just
keep it the way it is you know just how
about this do it right well it didn't
happen sometimes in recording of events
and and and exciting Excel are you
exciting moments in history like we're
recording this is what I feel like I
feel like you and your son did one of
those body switch things today and now
Finn is here trying to like get through
the show but just like why are we now
[ __ ] on my kid he's out of his
element that's the whole I don't want my
kid now my kids out of his [ __ ]
element is that what you're saying are
you you'll have fun hit and you know
dingers on the baseball field okay it's
a fun it's a it's a light vibe as all
it's a shitty movie trope that's been
done a million times it's been done once
one time it's done all the father like
son that it was what are you stupid
there's a movie out right now
what's it call its they're doing the
eyes they please they can see a fake
nose everyone's fake news look if you're
upset about fake news if what's going on
in the news is bothering you will talk
space as it's therapy that really fits
with today's world sure you you
understand like you're a guy and and
you're yeah well you're having a good
time right now because a report came out
and it made it seem like you didn't
actually work with an enemy country and
he's still going to put you need to put
brown people in cages on the border and
the other party totally [ __ ] up so
maybe sometimes you just call any anti
your therapist I think as it's been late
how awesome it is cuz now you might win
the election mites so it might not be
stressful between work family and
everything in between it's not easy to
find time for yourself talk space online
therapy
taking care of your mental health more
affordable and convenient than ever
before simply provide your preferences
for therapy and tox base will match you
with one of 4,000 ther plus therapists
the very same day send your therapist
unlimited text audio picture or video
messages from anywhere at any time and
no matter what you're going through
you're not alone join men more than 1
million people who are happier with talk
space including dawn talk space has more
than 4,000 licensed therapists or
experienced in addressing the challenges
we all face yeah like you you should to
match with your perfect therapist for a
fraction of the price of traditional
therapy go to talk space comm make sure
to use the code dollop to get forty five
dollars off your first month and show
you support for this show that's dollop
and talk space.com you should especially
check out talk space if you wear a
tinfoil hat the dollop is also supported
in people do come up to me and say that
they a lot of like I did a show of the
community in the other night and she was
saying how she is his talk space from
this show is that true yeah yeah
Canadian that's right comedienne and she
and she enjoys it yeah I've heard from
people who were like in places where
they can't like you're not in a city or
whatever there are a lot of therapists
around that it's very helpful yeah the
dollop is supported in part by Casper
not the ghost no one's made that joke
it's probably says in there please don't
make that it's a mattress situation it's
a sleep brand that continues to
revolutionize its line of products to
create an exceptionally comfortable
sleep experience one night Jose and I
sleep on a Casper everything you do you
and as I sleep Casper and I you do
cuddle how's the forehead to forehead
contact and one of those prayers and
that's what Casper is best at for his
right there on the Box they offer
affordable prices because Casper cuts
out the middleman and sells directly to
the customer right now but the middleman
is really getting screwed and so the
middle the middle
there's a beard in the meadows what the
[ __ ] I used to have a good thing going
how was your no you you took out your
Casper it came in a box comes in a box
that's too small to fit a mattress they
open it then you got a mattress it
expands and expands comes alive in front
of you and then it comes alive and then
it walks itself into your bedroom it
lays down on your whatever yeah and then
it and then you just put some sheets on
and you and and you sleep comfortably on
that bed board like a baby I mean I
guess better than a baby because they
wake up a lot yeah they do
Casper air mattress just combine
multiple supportive memory films for a
quality sleep service with the right
amounts of both sink and bounce do you
get a lot of Bounce on those bad boys
the bounces that's the best part yeah
hey now me it's a sink huh yeah you can
be sure of your purchase with Casper's
109th risk-free sleep on trial I like to
sink into it I like to sink into a
goddamn mattress that's my deal I sink
into one I'm Casper let's me sink yet
fifty dollars towards select mattresses
by visiting Casper comm slash table and
using a promo code dollop at checkout
additional fees may apply for Hawaii and
Alaska terms and conditions apply so I
apologize Hawaii and Alaska but you know
you guys said that was coming again you
got to be part of the the 50 at the 48
the lower 48 you guys are off doing your
thing move close I have a plan finally
it's gonna bring Hawaii in Alaska to
America
we are also brought to you by my
favorite toothbrush in the history of
mankind it is quip one of the most
important things we do every day
obviously is brushing our teeth yet most
of us don't do it properly which you
didn't before quip came along did you
that's against the British mr. Blair
says attack yeah I can't do that I'll
see you on Twitter I'm furious Wow
yeah so it's an electric toothbrush
created by dentists and designers it's
absolutely a wonderful multi-use cover
mounts to your mayor and unmount Stu
slide over your bristles for on-the-go
brushing yeah why declutter your sink
our cabinet and makes traveling with an
electric toothbrush easier clip doesn't
require a clunky charger and runs for
three months on one charge and you can
set up a subscription service and they
send you a new
for your toothbrush you pop on and then
a new battery and you're good to go back
in the game back in the game yep you're
right back in there yep
oh yeah so I've already done a couple of
those changes somewhere that's great
I've done a couple of subscription new
heads situations I don't think anybody's
asking for my drag of Spieth are sweet
awesome my Dennis that I have best teeth
in America
well you're Dennis sounds like a goddamn
idiot and I said this cuz equipment yeah
brush heads are automatically delivered
on a dentist recommended schedule every
three months for just five dollars why
three out of four of us use bristles
that are old worn-out or ineffective
equip is one of the first electric
toothbrushes accepted by the American
Dental Association it has thousands of
verified five-star reviews yeah yeah
that's so it's it's why they're backed
by over 20,000 dental professionals
equip starts at just $25 and if you go
to get quip comm slash stop right now
you get your first refill pack for free
with a quip electric toothbrush that's
your first refill pack free at GE t qu
IP comm slash dollop and of course last
but not least were brought to you by on
tuck it ever wonder
Gareth why traditional button ups look
so long and baggy I have wondered that
well that's because they were never
meant to be worn that way so why don't
you think about that for a little while
I have it wonder I have to untuck it
shirts
so I've already thought about okay so
you're not better than me untuck it
shirts were specifically designed to be
worn untucked hence the name yeah it
doesn't look like you know like you're a
kid who put on your dad's baseball
jersey I look like that and everything
untuck it actually don't look like that
and then tuck it I look like a man
that's what I'm saying
a grown man yeah but and everything else
you look like Tom Hanks I'll wear my own
took it surround the house with just my
untucking on dude stop talking like this
and it still looks good it still looks
tight too hot hot hot shirt no matter
what you're wearing in my case I'm
talking about without anything else yeah
we get it yeah it's the original
untucked shirt a modern solution to an
old problem with no tucking your
tailoring require
no matter your size or shape their
shirts are perfect untucked length IV I
don't you so you've had problems with
shirts in the past that look weird like
you like this doesn't work yeah that is
ah yeah well first of all I'm not
someone who I don't even mean to sound
like a pitchman but I'm not someone who
like when I go out shopping really you
know once the try stuff on who really
knows what I'm doing
quote-unquote yeah it's right so it's
hard to work a shirt machine yeah and
and so like I'll you know I'll buy a
shirt and then I'll get home I'll be
like I look weird I look like I look
like I lost a bunch of weight or
something like that and then because
it's too long but it like fits in part
yeah but then yeah so but until it's not
the same thing Nantucket works that's
what I'm saying I know that's what
you're saying I'm just hitting the point
harder that's why I'm hitting on with
more than 50 fit combinations untucked
shirts look great on tall short slim and
athletic guys of all ages
it's the armored hotdog of shirts that's
what we're talking about how well this
is on target fit your frame a very very
very well have you browsed online or
checked out their brick-and-mortar
stores you should check them out I'm
busy I can try it on in person at one of
untuk it's 50 stores or go to on Tucket
com2 get started they offer free
shipping and returns on all orders in
the US you can save 20% off your first
order by using our code dollop at
checkout that's untuk accom promo code
dawg we recommend we both like to have
any gigs you want I'll be at the
Moontower Comedy Festival April 25th
26th and 27th you can go to gareth
Reynolds come and see where i'll be
exactly and then you can also go there
because i have a bunch of dates coming
up but i'll plug those soon I'll be at
party boys party house all of July okay
and we should also say that if you want
to watch video of the podcast because we
are recording this one in the studio you
can go to the all things comedy youtube
page and if you want to see me at party
boys party house do not be like that
network please 24 don't go there I'll be
yeah I'll be in what's known as the hot
room
hmm doesn't sound like somewhere anyone
needs to go so we can it know it which
is believe it or not what getting worse
what are you talking about huh April
25th 1776 that's why there's no
photographs in this one or pictures or
anything well I come they actually do
not have photos no Instagram
no Oh Elinor Hooper was born in East a
Franklin Maine okay your favorite
I like Maine means great her parents
were David and Joanna Hooper David was a
veteran of the American Revolution
okay the couple would go on to have nine
children all together Eleanor came to be
called Nellie okay I guess that's short
for an Eleanor sure yep wooden Nellie
was 19 she met George Butler okay
he's a sea captain and that's a hot job
that's a hot job you come rolling off
the sea the ladies are like oh no I had
to tell them all how to die is that what
does he carry most of this but for the
most part it's telling people where to
put the bodies after they've died yeah
move some of these bodies over there are
you thinking of a like a mortician or
you same thing in this air okay all
right it just seemed yep take care
[ __ ] good to meet you oh yeah it was
great - yeah real contrarian idea wow
you're a captain yeah you're damn right
I am
what have you done huh exactly
I own the bank town that's awesome yeah
I don't have money I know I know
your captain yeah George's father was
one of the original settlers he's
Franklin so he's a he's an OG sure the
family very well off on the sawmill so
George is a catch Oh Dave you don't need
to tell me they're well off if they
owned a sawmill boom yeah yeah I'm sorry
I know it you're talking man I know the
money I know money I know economy's how
else you gonna cut down the tree parts
yeah what are you gonna do with your
parts the thing that goes into this yeah
we can do things gonna be gone if it
that don't have it in there how you
gonna make how you make the cheese stop
for your things how you make the cheese
in an industry that gets by without that
industry you talk about so I'm saying
that's and I'm saying George and Nellie
were married they lived on point Butler
which named after them obviously of
course well I would go there if there
was like a Reynolds island yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I was very forested area now they got
pregnant after a couple of years okay
things are going great sure
uh-oh but she died the day after she
gave birth Oh June 13 17 is real [ __ ]
oh yeah she's out of the story okay
Shetty good run we'll never hear from
her again she's dead it's your deal what
are you talking about very dark it's not
dark I'm just saying we're not gonna
hear you set it up she dead she's out
forget about her all right fine Nelly
Butler's gone she was buried in an
unmarked grave cool I know George is a
good guy George is like how about we
tell like she's not a thing uh we're
under a rock a shilling a word you say
so the baby's dead George's the wife is
dead it's all baby died - yeah yeah it's
a do-over do-over if that's what they
call them back then so fortunately it'll
be a do-over I guess this is a do-over
then yeah a mulligan I supposed is one
more shot isn't it after a couple years
George started to develop a relationship
with a Lydia Blaisdell why is Dell okay
he almost had yeah she lived about ten
miles away in Sullivan with her family
okay she's 15 years old
mm-hmm what oh it's the age is a problem
for me how old is George it's like 29
okay so yeah there's an issue there
you're sure yeah it's a problem why you
know because she's 15 what she's like I
like good I love what phase we're like
we didn't really know what like that was
like that is fine but it wasn't fine
actually then oh it wasn't yeah so so
he's gonna sense sort of comforting him
yeah so as things start ahead in the
direction of courtship her father made
it clear that he was not down with 29
year-old George he'll wait until she's
that's right coming around asking about
his daughter he's like that how about
you not do that and find a lady your own
age that's still alive but so for the
most part older men marrying teenage
girls was not how it was done
mein at the time they were not down with
it it's heartening right in fact in a
way it's just the yes it is citizen the
alternative right she was considered too
young and the age difference was you
know also issue right right
Abner blase tell her father lady's
father was also a vet of the American
Revolution very religious dude sure
super into the the God stuff the family
prayed together and tried to live life
the way God wanted them to right know
what a nightmare
yeah it wasn't great yeah his life's
mare his wife is Mary they had seven
kids they live on a hundred acre farm
okay that sounds pretty good that's not
bad yeah except for they're praying all
the time
yeah the praying all the time is the
problem yeah but I mean you can just
tune out yeah you too now you know the
main just I'd think it'd be like I get
that molasses I'm gonna go get a bunch
of molasses later that's what you think
happens during molasses that's an errand
well going to get molasses is an errand
there sure yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] if you
don't have a bunch of a look at us
Kenneth e Janice's house yep
that the sawmill you go grab some
molasses that's right you knew how
everything worked in the town I know the
general overview of the history of this
time yeah yeah and let me know if you
have any questions I don't I'm gonna
help you through some you're really
filling in the the holes that I have
you're welcome man sound like it being
in the hot room it's already boy let's
hot room is so [ __ ] great okay and
I'm in there all of July let's go the
town of Sullivan only had around 20
families everyone in town knew Abner it
was against George marrying Lydia this
makes me worried that George might be on
track to marrying Lydia because yours
well you're sort of setting up the
counter argument like yeah I just don't
think you'd do that unless we were to
sort of headed for destination you know
you know what's gonna happen just feels
like well maybe there's gonna be some
curveballs in here
abner had a quote notorious and
inflexible opposition to their
connection okay a hundred percent these
two are getting married whenever you're
ready to tell me in 1799 Lydia spent
most of her days in the cellar sorting
and picking wool fleece dreamed she
would in the [ __ ] she's living the
life this is a this young lady who's
living the dream all day in the cellar
picking on wool picking wool
yes picking the [ __ ] out of wool
in December she became very ill okay
very ill she's bedridden she was a
terrible fever she seems very near death
sure and as she lay in bed she heard
knocking sounds coming from the cellar
okay that's the wool Abner went down to
look found nothing and there's no no
reason for there to be knocking but
still to be certain he got the family
together and they all prayed smart it
better say sorry yeah exactly because
you didn't pray in this situation what
are you doing worst-case scenario you
just talked to God for a few minutes if
you don't a Hellmouth can open up down
there big time yeah they prayed that if
the knocking was a deception then God
would make it then God should make it
known to them but if the cause was
actually God then the noises might be
preserved so that's there so this is
without question the greatest error for
pranks yeah oh [ __ ] yeah this is when
you could just so easily convince
someone that you're God they're they're
basically saying if if it's God let's
have it keep going let's not say oh my
god Lord we are so humbled with your
presence Lord Lord why have you gone to
the cellar what do you need to
communicate to us Lord not good enough I
want you guys yes so we just started
[ __ ] everybody in town Lord it's
against the teachings Lord Oh
or not anymore just get out there and
start [ __ ] Lord even your terminology
is so Lord super in a [ __ ] and just
Lord Lord Lord in the hot dog Hakan
capaci
super tight balls Lord face loads Lord
Lord Lord Lord Lord Lord stop lord
please stop low guys know what a
blumpkin is a girls cover your ears
cover your ears the knighting sound in
the cellar kept coming back so now the
entire family start Aryan not just not
just sick Lydia sure a little while
later on a symptom of her death that's
right there's actual naught and then
she's actually getting better
the knocking is helping her yeah thank
you strong a little while later they
heard a disembodied voice how does one
jut what is a disembodied it means it
doesn't it sounds like it's like far
away or just like like Bali I don't know
like what's what's the word for it it
sounds like it's all throughout the
house kind of it's like a you know like
doesn't sound like coming from a
specific place it's like the house is
talking yeah well I mean no the house is
not talking but it the voice is coming
from inside so they can't see a they
can't see a person that's making the
voice so hmm it's a woman's voice hmm
is she speaking it's Kathy I couldn't
understand what it was saying at first
they head down to the bait the basement
and they'd find nothing down there
this goes on for a month for a month
what the voice yeah the knocking and
then the voice it's my whole [ __ ]
month yeah I mean within that month
you're at least I'm tossing out
alternative plans I got a lot of a
different ideas one of them is moving
moving is high Ottoman also I think I
can find what this is do you think you
can find what the I'm seriously not
living in a house where there is a
lady's voice just kind of coming from
every one of its God I then he's being a
real jerk-off
I might need to rethink things well Wow
she's being a real jerk-off
so after about a month the voice said
she would appear soon Abner told the
family to keep this on the down-low
don't tell you know not a great look in
the town to let everyone know that
there's ghosts in the cellar
yes 1790 family so it's like you got a
test pretty high yeah it's not it's not
a good time to be you know we gotta go
so so what are you guys doing Yeah right
yeah all right because they're like oh
nothing Abner all right tonight we have
to cook Abner's brains and eat them
that's right it's the only way so the
voice would dart around the cellar so if
they go down there the voice would be
Bing Bing Bing Bing darting around this
is insane and then the voice claimed to
be on a mission from God it's a blues
brother that exactly this is the first
blues brother store Jane blues this is a
prequel Wow
anjing On January 2nd of the female
ghost waited up here in the cellar is
this can be Nelly she would stand there
shrouded in white
so was this now their ghost is there
they don't often follow through right
yeah well this is a ghost that's up to
her word she's [ __ ] standing by a seat
toy
she's now I'll talk Lassie she told the
blaze dales she was the ghost of Nelly
Butler okay that girl's back
I mean you miss you sittin you said we
wouldn't hear from her you did very
explicit but she was dead I had to had
assumed that that would end the carrot
usually that wraps up the carrot that is
the end normally so now that's been dead
at three years at this point and here
she is
so ghost Nelly told Abner she was there
to get Lydia and George married and she
didn't just want it chief they've
ordered that it happened she order David
David quote Dave the parties must and
would be
join way and what God hath joined
together let no man put asunder right
now let me walk you through a scenario
that I find go possible a lady has died
our child has that's right that's right
her widower uh-huh
has found a 15 year old that's right
that he likes and the family because of
just general conviction but potentially
religious conviction as well have said
no that's right to the Union and now the
dead wife correct has come back yet to
be like he needs a new wife and she
should be that teenager yeah welcome to
America buddy
no this is classic America how illogical
now I'm gonna flip may I see to theory
early hmm I don't think this is Nellie
Wow yeah you're so cynical ah
I'm more positive and more believing in
not on stuff that's wonderful and I
think this is now yeah it's a love story
from beyond the grave
just your ex matchmaking from the other
side that's how it happened some time
came all the way back to make sure that
these two kids don't pass up an
opportunity for a fruitful bond mmm
also give me the kids teeth two things
two teeth Abner obviously not about to
stand in the way what God wanted play
when God talks you through ghost dead
mom no you don't say no to that how it's
a [ __ ] would you like the 12 year old
- good lord
Cinelli ghost then told Abner and Lydia
to go see George's father to tell him
Nellie wanted them to get married okay
wait goes to a ghost Nellie
Abner and Lydia okay the two of them go
- not George but George is rad and say
that Nellie's a narc in our basements
ghost and she would like she's near a
bunch of wolves
so she also wanted them to tell George's
father a verse of scripture okay quote
for this reason a man will leave his
father and mother and be united to his
wife the two will become one flesh they
are no longer two but one flesh
therefore his little son yeah therefore
what God has joined together let no one
separate so she's using a little bit of
scriptures throw a little scripture
Abner's way so he's like okay this is
for sure her and it makes her seem a
little more like validate yes she's got
she sees the voice of God God is giving
her cliff notes he's been like this
nobody else would use Scripture no no no
no so off Lydia and Abner go there's a
terrible blizzard out boy no they head
out immediately okay so they're going
through this nightmare they could say
God he said waited till it calms down
out there really bad out there so they
go across ice sheets on the tonton River
during the journey Lydia said she's not
down for getting married she doesn't
want to marry George but you know God is
you know talking to them through a ghost
in their cellar so this story's got lots
of fun variants yeah yeah
Lydia also that she really didn't think
it was great they were doing this just
because it ghost told them to in other
words
Lydia is how would we say logical
fifteen-year-old kid who's like what
okay I don't want to marry a grown man
and also that's pretty I'm pretty sure
that's a character actress but wow this
is going on Nelly appeared in front of
them out in the middle of you know Hey
and she consoled Lydia encouraged them
to keep going yes Mary that's what I had
to come here to tell you so they finally
get to George's dad's house they
explained I explained the situation
there's like okay so there's a ghost boy
I actually
Hertz this because this is gonna sound a
little bananas sir now that I'm gonna
have to pitch it back to you well you
remember Nellie yeah Oh George's or my
daughter-in-law abysses daughter-in-law
buried no longer yes the Lord has sent
her back she's been living in our
basement from you much I'm sorry she
started by kind of throwing her voice
what around the house but then
eventually the apparition appeared
I don't anyway let me we're out we
almost died getting here brother we saw
her last night
we started literally last night we some
guys should leave no no can't in this
storm
we'll die have you been eating the
mushrooms that you find underneath the
cow I first of all you sound like a cool
guy for sure and I would love to talk
about that another Junction okay but
right now I'm here to tell you that
Nellie has said that that George and
Nellie is Ian Ellie's death who is fit
Nellie is not dead she's around a bunch
of wool in my cellar [ __ ] okay
and she's gave me a Bible verse and so
here's my daughter Lydia she is very
young she is inappropriately young and I
put my foot down more I could not have
at the Union ship but the Lord has told
Nellie who again lives where my prisoner
she's dead but now as a ghost and and so
Georgia and Lydia have to get married
and Lydia is kind of opposed to it she's
been a real stick in the mud
just because he's twice her age and
that's creepy oh okay this all sounds
good
what are you cooking I'd love to come in
and have a bite that's a head I don't
believe so George's dad was also
George's dad is also against George
marrying his 15 year old he's so really
the only person on board would this is
George and the ghost it seems like it
Abner explained that his dead
daughter-in-law was the one who wanted
to happen
Abner even dropped the scripture on
George's dad but he's not having it
George tells George dad says get get the
[ __ ] out of here he's disgusted they had
come with such a story it's like this is
just [ __ ] nonsense oh shoot I didn't
make this up don't come into my house
with a bunch of ghost [ __ ] you didn't
make it up oh there's a ghost what
basement who wants my prepubescent
daughter to marry my old son get the
[ __ ] out of here weirdo crazy [ __ ]
back onto the blizzard maybe you guys
will die and come back as ghosts and
tell me to I'll make sandwiches or
whatever
like get the [ __ ] out of here good to
meet you sir yeah nice to meet you but
then after they left George's dad starts
thinking in the situation over sure and
he's like except minute to process this
he's like why would they come in such
crazy weather yeah they're basically
risking their lives and then he also
knew Abner had always been against the
marriage so it doesn't really add up
yeah so when Liddy and Abner get home
George wants you back go back through
the storm what no no he starts not like
a nose fell off
Nellie starts knocking down in the
cellar how are you not great he's not
really down he go back now no he's into
it he's not into it go yes I changed his
mind what I would like is some food I'm
gonna go upstairs I knew a peckish corn
ghost
we're gonna have some gore per me a
sandwich cotton also some rum so they go
down there and they talk to the ghost
Gianelli again and this time she says
we'll go get my dad David Hooper and
bring him bring him here he's gonna love
this yeah he's gonna be like my girl so
this is another this is another six mile
journey through the storm so they decide
well let's wait till morning on this one
no now it must be but the storm is
pretty bad even in the morning but they
still head out okay they go all the way
to Franklin where David Hooper here's
the story and he's like yeah no I'll go
see my daughter's ghost okay yeah yeah I
mean I'm it's weird I'd expected I have
a ghost jacket and then I have just like
a winter totally
so then Lydia and Abner were told to go
see George Butler after they told David
Nellie's dad right so they go to George
Butler and they're like hey you're your
ex you're I don't know what we call her
you're almost you're dead you're your ex
wipe new year old wife the dead wife
right she's actually in our cellar she's
glowing she's white she's saying all
that stuff she's pretty chatty right and
George is like oh okay I'll come I'll
cruise over and so David is already on
his way and now George is headed over
there cool
David emotionally yeah it's gonna be a
big day big ghost day yeah
so David Hooper arrives at the Blaisdell
home first in the afternoon give us out
of the basement Oh super shocked to see
his daughter as it goes sir it's super
weird Hey hi I live in the basement near
all the wool hey hey I guess I miss I do
miss you but this is also super the only
thing I need to get done is for Lydia
and George to get married what it's my
mission now that's your mission yeah its
crew weird but it's not God works in
really weird way no that's a god okay
that makes me some rum yep
put it down here you're gonna do what he
can do with that you're gonna sacrifice
turn your back and it'll go away
what wait how can you drink if you're I
didn't huh you went gulp I'm okay I
don't wanna see ya so david has a chat
with the ghosts and he's convinced as
his daughter sure David wrote quote by
the request of the spectre sent by two
messengers I went to Abner Blaisdell
house and by conversing with with she
obtained such a clear and irresistible
tokens of her being the spirit of my own
daughter as gave me no less satisfaction
than admiration and delight she gave a
reason satisfactory to me why she put me
to the trouble of coming there instead
of coming to my house
it's just the storm is worse for ghosts
I couldn't I didn't know make mittens on
this side so I did want to go back to
your house dad because I know mom keeps
a lot of canning and stuff in the cellar
and also you guys have the washing
machine and it's quieter here and then I
also thought woman goes so maybe I
should freak out people I don't know
I can't travel also you guys I mean I'm
an adult and it's just a bummer to live
with your parents you know if you're a
ghost all the other goes to think it's
weird I'm looking at a condo so then
George shows up right so David's are
very excited his daughter's bash a ghost
so then David shows up a bunch but I'm
open as the ghost now he doesn't have a
bunch of returning feelings once she
sees joy god I know right then talk
about rom-com boy so David David comes
in he's brought a friend
wait George George George brought a
friend sorry there's brought a friend
yeah wouldn't you bring a friend we hang
out wouldn't it be like hey you're your
ex's down and my basements of ghost when
you be like hey Frank gonna come with me
and this is a little weird no every
weird yeah I mean every answer is weird
yeah definitely be like no I'll do this
I want to go see my ghost well you
wouldn't bring a buddy would bring Luke
you and be like hey Luke can I go see my
ex ghost well if I mean yeah so so they
he gets there after David has already
finished talking with his dead daughter
and then George goes down and talks to
the ghost and he's convinced it's Nellie
uh-huh you know in my head I'm thinking
George is behind this yeah well it could
be but maybe it's a ghost
quote when I was called to talk with
this voice I asked who are you
it answered I was once your wife well
the voice asked me do you remember what
I told you when I was alive yeah I
answered I do not really know what you
mean
and the voice said do you remember I
told you I did not think I should live
long with you I told you that if you
were to lead me I should never wish to
change my condition but that if I was to
leave you I could not blame you if you
did
judge like wow this is something only
Nellie would have known what is
happening so she's saying she she
basically did not think she was gonna
live a long life and so he thinks
because she said that that she would
only have told him that but there's no
way any any woman's also gonna tell her
friends that like she's gonna be like
I'm so I'm so scared I'm gonna die young
like that's just a thing hey so he but
he thinks well that she could always
told me starting I'm the guy starting to
think ghosts yeah yeah quote there was
something appeared to my view right
before me
like a person in a winding-sheet and her
arms folded under the winding Shango I
can't this sheet is too long I've come
back to say untangle someone help that
don't pull out slide it only tightens
yeah it cuts the circulation if you do
it there and then this hand
oh my god I don't owe it my gifts
[ __ ] foots in it now they don't give
a blanket instruction and ghosts yes
scissors this was a total redo work I
should have gone to the ghost
orientation I didn't go now I'm wrapped
in blankets oh by this okay her arms
folded under the whining sheet and on
her arm there appeared to be a small
child what yeah what is doing it it's
the baby I know who it is
yeah by this appearance I did not know
possibly but I might be deceived I
reached out my left hand to take hold of
it I saw my hand in the middle of it but
could feel nothing the same evening it
appeared and disappeared to me three
times so he put it he reaches out and he
and his arm goes through the ghost is it
the same people who did a hologram Tupac
is that the big reveal it's the same
technology I knew it
George's friend was there and watched
the whole thing and confirmed that he
saw George's hand passed through ghost
Nellie
Hey so David Hooper father of the Denali
right he goes to see George's dad who's
a member is resistant to this whole yes
great but sort of thought a little once
he realized thee yeah he's thought a
little bit and he and David tells him
yes the ghost thing is true and she's
hanging out in the cellar of the blaze
Dells and he spoke to her tangled up in
a sheet she's a hell of a ghost she's a
hell of a ghost
it's a Houdini Dini and he says guess
what it's her that's my daughter
and he wants he wants George to marry
Lydia she wants Georgia marry the ghost
yeah so George's dad was like okay fine
and this yeah I mean I get it just makes
sense so just to be clear to get a head
count there's now no resistance except
for Lydia but it seems like everyone's
pretty on board yeah
well George is obviously gonna be on
board yep yeah it's him so so George's
dad's in after all this is clearly God's
will right mhm so on January 5th
George's dad headed over to the blase
Dale's and said he was on board he would
he would let George marry Lydia is there
going to be a more awkward ceremony it's
not gonna be great okay that's gonna be
a little odd okay so both a brother the
bride father the groom father of the ex
deceased bride Oh deceased ladies this
bride thank you for coming here to see
dead deceased baby
and of course George's friend so both
Abner George's dad are still not
thrilled that this is happening but they
feel like well this is God's will so we
don't really have a choice right yeah
yeah he may he were again this is what
people forget he works in mysterious
ways which is no lateral raises carte
blanche yes so that's why he appears in
toast or sometimes dogs anuses or a tree
or tree or you know I'm sorry if you see
dogs anus mmm-hmm what's happened to
someone thought their dog said something
like that yeah it was a butthole or but
I would just recommend if that a view if
you're feeling that maybe you're looking
too close to the dog's butthole
well I mean do I mean yes I mean I guess
that has you really gotta be staring a
dog's butthole to see Jesus in there
that's like the ten minute after miracle
question yeah hey Andy why were you
staring at it so long I was trying to
see first I was trying to see if I could
see like like boats or different kind of
shapes like that you know you look at
anus and try to figure out what it
resembles what's inside it it's like a
magic hi me what do you have a dog yeah
what do you walk in it so the two
fathers set the date of the wedding may
29 2014 6 to go sting in her own
basement to trick George into marrying
her but but wasn't it was it not George
who wanted to marry her and she was
resistant I guess maybe she could after
the fact be feigning resistance to but
still George was into it right what a
girl who invented a ghost act like she
didn't want to get married don't take on
the role of the narrator talking to you
but was he ever resistant to it he was
into it
no he's into it ok ok but I think she's
into it too I think that she you know
was into him ok
because they were because they were
hanging out together they were he was
like cruising by the house like it
clearly was a connection there it's a
cool guy
so some thought the apparition was
actually a demon or at least demon
familiar well at least that there are
logical counter are yeah that's right
people are you know people come with
other stuff fools it's not an apparition
it's a demon she clearly a demon or
demon familiar thank you where the demon
faction one of Nellie's sisters went to
see the ghost with her husband
Lydia spoke to the ghost and the ghost
answered but this was not the voice
Nellie's sister expected hmm when the
voice said quote I am the voice of one
crying in the wilderness which is what
that's classic ghost talk ya know almost
hacky legalese actually the sisters real
the sister realized this was not
Nellie's normal voice no no no she's
doing a girl in the woods impression
it's not great look if you are not on
board with the idea that this ghost is
now in the basement doing some sort of
director real yeah you're out of your
mind no I totally agree
come on I'm testing out some new
material I'm doing impressions really
yeah so the so the sisters like that's
not Nellie's normal voice but it's the
voice that Nellie had when she was sick
and dying in bed I am just I'm hanging
on a lot of these words waiting for the
logic yeah yeah no it's all logic you're
getting this this is all this is all the
logs okay logic okay so this person is
now there like she does have sick voice
my guess is when you die with sick voice
you maintain it well her sister then
thought that this was because of the
voice this was evil at work a demon is
inside of Nellie dingo quote from this
time I cleared Lydia as to the voice and
accused the devil huh okay so we've got
our demon cam Parnelli camp in our devil
camps okay
others started coming by to visit the
okay captain Paul Simpsons can't captain
Paul Simpson came because one of Abner's
sons kept insisting that he check it out
sure so one of the sons was like dude
you got to see this [ __ ] ghost man
it's busy no captain
it's [ __ ] crazy go excuse me but I'm
busy looks like his ship stuck in a AB
article itself okay
she's talking scripture well I do like
that she's all wrapped up she didn't
oughta get out of her blanket or
whatever sure I love a tangled blanket
and she's like telling people to hook
all right let's go so he goes to the
cellar the son puts out the candle
because they hate you they always blow
out the candle before the apparition
would appear yeah
again there are limitations as to what
they can do in the afterlife
some of them need a candle blitz right
like a birthday yes so they both can all
they wait and then the knocking comes
[Music]
look alive look alive and then the
captain spoke and Nellie said quote
prepare ye the way of the Lord make his
paths straight seek ye the Lord while he
may be found call upon him while he is
near and then the captain what and then
and then the captain and ghost Nellie
chatted for a while she apparently was
very good with words she had a way with
words sure she really knew how to win
people over sure super time it goes
quote after a little discourse with her
their fears were easily dissipated and
succeeded base I know it sounds crazy
it's I if I heard it I would think it's
crazy no I would think this was total
[ __ ] I would be like no way but here
and I'm the one telling you so I totally
get it I'm like I'm the ghost and I'm
like this is bananas succeeded by
singular pleasure so delightful was the
mode of her addressing conversation so
she stood it for buying he's good at
talking yeah pretty soon everyone was
stopping by to get a look at chat with
the ghost of Nellie Butler hey what's up
hi Hey all right please send in someone
else the Baker's out there all the
Baker's great oh maybe we do it in a big
group of Baker's it's yeah I guess but
better that way than doing individual
bangles for me it's just you know I've
been doing this all day yeah three days
it's just been non-stop I think people
would think that was rude if you'd sure
we could do them one-on-one but I'm not
gonna spend a bunch of time with them
but so it's just mostly a question ready
I guess it's a photo and then they want
like a signature and then five minutes
my hand like a five minute chat I can't
be doing five minute chats for all the
Baker's or all it's just it's not Paul I
have a life I have to go back to ghost
town - I have a whole thing there I have
a family there I'm like are there like
what's going on in the cellar I'm like
it's nuts you know look the point is
just bring in one of the [ __ ] Baker's
let's go Matt seems like demon talk no
I'm just sorry it's no no no I forgive
forgive me oh you have somewhere to be
like a demon house no it's none of that
no is a Hellmouth nearby that you have
to go back please just send in some
Baker's let's just do this thank you
maybe people maybe be nicer I said I was
sorry I've been doing this a lot for the
past couple of days this is pretty hard
I said - what do you tell it's not great
demonic I have no it's a demon million
bring them I'm excited to me [ __ ]
bakery okay there's the having trouble
okay so everyone's stopping by to have a
chat with Nellie Butler she would often
tell them what else not going to tell
you now late there's another thing she
would also often tell them quote fear
not one one of edge even jealous who
stopped by
she has catchphrases now yeah he stopped
by on his travels and said he thought
she would knock said he thought she
would knock first to avoid scaring
people so he's like that's why she's
knocking first cuz she doesn't want to
just pop in and be like oh so it's like
a slow intro kind of thing Yeah right
he also said she only appeared in the
cellar because that allowed the
Blaisdell family to be able to be ghost
free upstairs absolutely and I think of
course you I think you know let's say
there's five percent of the people
listening to this they think that sounds
crazy now no you guys are wrong yeah
okay when you think about it that the
basements where you keep your wool
that's right and the last thing you need
is some sort of someone ghost in your
upstairs go stand around well you're in
your kitchen eater just the hand eggs
look fantastic
yeah that's not yeah that's it comic
yeah that's not the vibe wing that's not
a ghost Nelly was not in any way a
normal ghost she I'm a dreamer I just
come over at certain points and you look
I can juggle cats yeah she quote
exhibited all the mental and emotional
characteristics of a living human being
well that should not be selling you
that's not-- that's how [ __ ] super
ghosty she is no real human she was also
super into the affairs of the living she
pees she's one of them
she's also super into the affairs of the
living if she seemed motivated by
personal vengeance vanity I'm opening a
bank account and arranging the marriage
okay so so she's just from beyond the
grave maybe like a wedding planner yeah
yeah I have a show on HGTV every ghost
has a thing I think this would be nice
that bouquet is perfect
she also often announced where and when
she would show up next I'm doing at 7:30
and then at 9:45 it's the same show so I
you know don't come to both
and she invited people to quote come and
handle me what
so they cuz no one contender's over like
right go and put your hands up punch
through me which they would this just
increased some people's belief that
ghost Nellie was a fraud
she didn't at all act like a ghost this
is not like all the other ghosts that I
have met I've met a lot of ghosts and
none of them are chatty or like hey give
me a hug or we are joined in the demon
party we have pretty positive it's dead
women it's definitely a demon we're not
crazy what else gonna be also but my
friend was saying it might be demon
familiar I'm not opposed to that theory
it is wild but I definitely think it is
a demon potentially outside chance team
and familiar outside of that nothing
logically makes sense okay yes but
Nellie
ghost ghost Nellie was not just
appearing in the cellar now she started
popping up in different houses I'm doing
a tour the next seven houses on the way
summons four seven thirty nine forty
come out some as far as five miles away
sometimes she showed up outside one of
the Blaisdell sons said he saw the ghost
kicking it out in the fields around
their house cool property yeah what's
your property law I'm trying to get
apples but every time I reach for that
my hand goes through the apple looks
like it should be a solid harvest from
what I can tell this is so great he just
beyond the Sun grain anyway okay I'm
holding my baby
hey this is outside so she said she
didn't touch he said she didn't touch
the ground she was like floating above
us sure that son was actually not
thrilled about the ghost Nellie the
whole time he'd spoken out against her
to other people in the town right so
soon she told him that she had come on
behalf of God and speaking against her
was speaking against God dropping the
hammer right yeah news of the go spread
to nearby towns I would imagine that at
the time this will it spread everywhere
what is more interesting than being like
there's a ghost to talk to there's
really nothing else happening everything
else you're doing is like oh we was just
watching a dog that's it for how long
four months he just walks a bunch we
think we've seen Jesus in his but oh God
yeah and that's what we said okay it
sort of talks yeah this is why the the
picture says don't look at a dog's butt
for so long yeah well what else gonna do
okay that's fair yeah so people start
making the journey from around the
around the country or around the area
right to see ghost Nellie yeah for sure
there were so many people now they would
pack into the cellar okay so let's go
Sally would come and she would often
talk to the crowd for two or three hours
to cover a bunch of different topics
what I mean okay look I understand that
like their their minds had not really
adjusted like there's stuff we do that
we have yet to fathom for sure yeah
but I mean she's doing like full-on TED
Talks yeah you're kind of sold-out
houses yeah I mean look she's a big
attraction what else is going on like
you said three hours everything man she
[ __ ] come houses are crazy huh they
ask your questions she answers the all
topic she's covering all kinds of [ __ ]
I'm running for president fine I'm down
okay
a witness quote at first the apparition
was a mere mass of light then grew and
tape into a personal form about as tall
as myself we stood in two ranks about
four or five feet apart between these
ranks she slowly passed and re-passed so
that any of us could have handled her
when she passed me her nearness was that
of contact so that if there had been a
substance
I should have certainly felt it the glow
of the apparition had a constant tremolo
motion so deny that [ __ ] don't
the talk really had some real [ __ ] dude
I don't know touching ghosts they're
getting cocky watch them ghost bounce
around you just what's up with the
marriage and we'll get to that right now
we're just we're just kidding up with a
bunch of folks
she's just got all Hollywood well she's
she's people like her you know what
she's doing cocaine I can't do an
apparition unless I have my two bumps
I'm like Stevie Nicks blow it in me not
everyone bought it some just thought the
idea of a ghost was [ __ ] and it had
to be a demon or it was something Lydia
had brought forth it was using
witchcraft uh-huh so another option huh
and some thought Lydia and her sister
Hannah were using deception and trickery
creating this whatever this fraud to get
George to Mary imagine those people
became increasingly vocal as time wore
on uh-huh they noted that ghost Nellie
never appeared in a house that Nellie
had actually lived in I won't yeah why
I'm just trying to look at all the other
properties but this like this like blows
the idea what a ghost is a ghost uh-huh
you'd blow the ghosts don't hang in
places they've never been yeah yep for
sure we do we love doing that we do that
a lot
what other ghost is them I just don't
want to go where I've lived that's weird
okay you don't understand also the
Blaisdell cellar was only ever lit by a
candle or two meaning someone else could
be hiding down there and the cellar had
during during these visits from beyond
yeah at no point are people like
inspecting the area with light well they
yeah they really can't because there's
one or two candles and then they get
blown out when the knocking starts and
then they're in the darkness until the
ghost appears the cellar also had two
other ways in there's a window covered
by a wood and then a door to the outside
okay
so there's a backstage at what point a
local guy snuck in and tried to
impersonate the ghost but everyone
caught on pretty quick he was grabbed it
turned out it was John I ran a 33 year
old shoemaker and they threw him out of
the house okay so the shoemaker was like
my have a little fun let me show you
[ __ ] it's true what they say
best sense of humors
blurs lydia say I'm opening for Lydia
said she's actually not sure about the
ghost she told their friends as she
considered running away before the
wedding day came mm-hmm she actually
came up with a plan to stow away on a
ship and go to York where the family had
relatives but then she told George and
broke off the engagement George was not
happy because he was a perv obviously
he's gonna marry a fifteen-year-old
right yeah naturally ghost Nellie heard
about this plan to run away I'm pin the
breaking off that is that's bad she
confronted Lydia [ __ ] in front of
several witnesses in the cellar so
there's a bunch of people down there she
gets in her fan I don't mean to do this
in front of people but what is your deal
I'm a ghost you [ __ ] has she
told Lydia to stay she told Lydia if she
left quote her afflictions would sail
with her that's right so she's basically
saying wherever you go I'm [ __ ] going
[ __ ] unless it's in the house
and then not I can't or I could go to my
house then you're fine I guess yeah stay
here so at that point Lydia's like okay
and she agrees to marry George they get
married on May 29th and that argument
was in front of people yes right yeah
interesting interesting yeah so if you
keep track this means the ghost has been
hanging around talking to people for
about six months yeah probably is ready
to do the hour the day after the wedding
Nellie ghosts visited the newlyweds Hey
hey what are you guys doing pork in
front of me who can i watch my this
whole thing was about this real weird I
want to see Jordan I'm gonna jump in
Lydia's body and it'll be me yeah let me
see so she told she told them that Lydia
was not gonna live very much longer then
it'll be me and her picking you next one
she said Lydia was gonna get pregnant
have a child and then
soon after having the child what yeah
yeah pretty much like what had happened
in Delhi yeah well exactly after the
ghost dropped that bombshell
she stopped appearing in the cellar and
so then George and Lydia had to live
with all the rumors and whispers from
locals and and and it increased like
people got more and more upset about it
right the ghost is gone right a lot of
people think she's it's it's fraud a lot
of people think it's a demon
so shit's heating up yeah
and then it goes on is really sort of
reaching a fever pitch and then BOOM
Nelly reappears Hey hi back in the
cellar again and the chorus equal people
flock back to the cellar to get a look
at ghosts Nelly again she's doing props
that's right starting in August eighteen
hundred a hundred people saw her in the
cellar okay so she's selling out yeah
it's a big [ __ ] show yeah putting the
sell and seller it's the same thing
every time the ghost and invite them
into the cellar they go down and they'll
be dark all right I've never blow out
the candle then there'd be the knocks
then the white ghosts would appear and
start talking I heard a new song or
whatever it's great yeah so what played
a new song in the Fife but not everyone
could see her at the same time some
people like she'd be right in front of
someone and the person next to them
would say they couldn't see her what
kind of what are they working here I
don't know others would be like no she's
right here
sometimes everyone would gather and she
wouldn't appear at all I'm not doing the
show tonight I feel tired and it's just
a drain there's so many Negative Nancy
my throat the reviews are awful
she was always in a glowing white dress
or shroud sometimes she had on a cap
sometimes no cap sometimes she'd be
holding a dead wrap
baby okay so there's it looks yeah this
different adopts options sometimes she
would hang back ten feet of the time she
would lean in and speak right into
people's ears some kept saying this is
[ __ ]
especially because the ghost voice would
come first then she would order everyone
to leave the cellar and come back so
what so then so we can break this down
she says there won't come
Abner goes down with a candle he blows
it out it's dark yeah there's knocking
then the voice goes okay everybody
upstairs now leave me alone for a minute
it's ghost stuff and then they come back
down and that's when sheet appears a
glowing white ghost okay so so that's
not that's pretty normal it's not normal
one man noted quote that's weird it's it
was always she or one of the blazed ELLs
who would who always controlled the
condition to her appearance okay so yeah
this opens the suspect list a little but
eight times the ghost did not tell
people to leave and come back she just
appeared glowing in ghost farm in front
of them what's going on also usually
Abner would blow out a candle and plunge
the cellar into darkness before they
ghosts appear I said that one local man
Jeremiah bunker said the ghost shape
shifted finally a rational mind in the
group it appeared and disappeared
several times quote the personal shape
on a disappeared first change to a
substance without form then vanished the
full personal form appeared again in a
moment these changes I observed several
times one constant argument was that the
voice was clearly Lydia okay when
someone said that Nellie would send
Lydia way and then keep talking now what
bit what's up now quote about fourteen
persons by the direction of the specter
went into the cellar as soon as they
were there the specter said to Lydia
Blaisdell go up and sit with others in
the kitchen hearth
that this company may know that it is
not you who speaks after she was gone up
the ghost conversed with the company on
several topics suited to authenticate
her mission okay so tonight I'll talk
about God
snakes Prince he's got a new album out
awesome and I guess the show Mama's
family
oh it's a Christian yeah those are the
topics tonight I can't wait yeah she
told people to get as close to her as
they wanted and ask whatever they wanted
no they would also talk about her life
to convince people that she was Nellie
that's a nightmare she talked about only
stuff George knew about and then as if
George remembered and he'd say yes so
they're all down there or just now like
also part of the Act I think they're all
down there George do you remember that
Jorah I do see is that crazy yeah then
another time with George okay we were
sitting around eating some bread and
George said should we toast the bread
and what did I say do you remember what
I said George he said yeah I said yeah
yeah and then do you know what happened
oh yeah what happened no dude the bread
yeah all right so that ends the George
portion yeah this was great can I go no
no no I'll sit here friend might be
behind this okay
one day she told Abner that his dad was
in heaven good news I just figured it
out well his dad was still alive was
Abner thoughts but it turns out his dad
had been sick and it died seven days
before and the family in New York had
not yet sent news by sending news for a
deceased father took that long yeah but
the ghost knew the ghost knew about
Abner's mm-hmm
by mid-august Nellie's a hot ticket
seller is [ __ ] packed yeah
but the more guys move a little we got
to keep room for the fire exit
come on excuse me fire department here
this is way overcrowded this is a
capacity 35 we've got at least 50 in
here your son is ill what your son's ill
no yeah yeah Jimmy's fine I'll go home
and look I left him in Boston he was
fine go home and look at go to Boston
don't go to Boston in this the blizzard
go through this go to Boston do this go
do this all right now I'm gonna do stuff
that I did with George one of my big
heads the more packed the cellar got the
more others talk about the demonic [ __ ]
that was going down in the blaze Dale's
basement in response the ghost started
preaching and talking about religion one
guy asked her if she loved Christ and
she said she did then she started
singing Hallelujah
what she can't be with the devil oh I
actually just recently became a
Christian it's so weird but now I
identify with a religious sect a local
came down to the cellar a couple of days
later to confront the ghost he had been
going around the village saying the
ghost was the devil's doing ghost Nellie
told him quote you have often said that
I am a devil or a witch I am from above
praising God and the lamb yeah a few
days woman after that a woman asked her
if she came from happiness or misery and
Nellie said she was from above and came
with God's message then she broke into
hallelujah and also with these albums
are for sale on the way out
yeah on the night the by us a bunch of
people who thought this was all fraud
and [ __ ] like tricks you know came
to the cellar things got very heated and
physical there was pushing and shoving
sure some of the guys started showing
they could copy the knocks of ghost
Nellie oh oh yeah oh yeah the girls like
how the knock is the thing that you like
see yeah yeah I could copy in operation
Abner threw them all out like a bouncer
so he's now I could ghost bounce enough
one of those guys was Paul Simpson the
whole thing got really bought really
bugged him and as he walked home he
decided if he would get to the bottom of
what he thought was fraud and so he
turned around on my back that's it
Abner let Paula to the cellar and told
him to light a candle and look around as
much as he wanted he said Paul wood
could grab anyone who appeared meaning
one only one person is gonna pay yeah so
you know the shortlist yeah Paul waited
until everyone it's not just Nellie's
gun if you find any others feel free to
tackle anything down here you can touch
it's fair game
this is our [ __ ] room okay so Paul
waited until everyone left and made sure
the door was locked
I sure he's alone and then the knocking
began okay then Nelly appeared but this
time it was weird
first the ghost was five feet high and
then it moved close to him and became as
tall as a normal person and went back
and forth past him five times then
shrunk down to a foot tall and then
disappeared I'm little now so that's
some [ __ ] showing off right there or
it's not like I'm bringing it yeah oh
what's up mister I don't believe in me
yeah that's right yeah people in the
towns of Franklin and Sullivan
inflection we're released yeah we're
really starting to get into heated
arguments about the ghost or demon or
fraud camps formed on the night of
August 13th 47 people came to the
Blaisdell house to see ghosts Nellie she
was apparently prepared for it and was
ready for a confrontation I
let's do this at 1:00 a.m. she told them
all to walk to a house two miles away it
was the house of James Miller it was a
huge loudmouth skeptic okay
so go slowly Nellie told them to walk in
in groups of two right so side by side
and sing the eighty 84th psalm the
entire time they walked okay and goes no
I said she follow them I'll be right
behind you guys as they walked a few
said they did see her walking with them
while others said yeah there hey yes so
some saw her and some didn't yeah okay
what is going on when she finally got to
the Miller house everyone packed inside
one of the Blaisdell boys asked if
Miller would go down to the cellar with
him and Miller said sure we're gonna
sell it with you see you're [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] nonsense okay when they
got down there the voice of ghost Nellie
said loudly quote I have come to let you
know that I can speak in this cellar as
well as the other are you convinced I
only do cellars okay and Miller's like
up [ __ ] yeah this is awesome
I'm totally in no more skeptic he goes
up to to talk to the crowd who have now
moved back outside in front of his house
and then they waited for ghost Nellie to
return and she did right there and then
right toward them yeah in front of the
house yes and then she told them all the
walk keep walking go walk more more
we're gonna walk again it was really
good to do after dinner in two twos you
bite you will sing another song yep the
ghost
okay this time ghost Nellie said she was
gonna walk besides Lydia who was going
to be the front of the pack okay she's a
gal pal we've really bonded
the ghost shed she was doing this to put
an end to all the talk that Lydia was
behind a deception or that she was a
witch as they walked people watched as
Lydia and ghost Nellie walked beside
each other and sang a hymn together even
the skeptics we haven't duets album ever
ones like I am an okay after this March
the skeptics and believers who thought
that it was a devil or whatever were
pacified this is a big [ __ ] show and
everyone's like um this is I'm in I'm
[ __ ] in ghost Nell even said she
wanted her dead baby dug up and buried
closer to her grave a little cocky what
little cocky but no everyone now she's
convinced everyone so now she's [ __ ]
all the babies go big or go home
all the babies dig up your baby and get
it buried closer to you go big or go
home
so she tells him she wants her baby dug
up and put close to her grave this way
they could go to heaven together on
Judgment Day and everyone's like yeah
that's so that's not still a fair
request dig up your baby for sure we do
the thing is we dig up babies and move
them out all the time I just have a
purpose behind it for once on the be the
day of the excavation 80 people from
four towns came to watch a baby get dug
up the baby's corpse was moved 30 feet
up the hill and placed next to Nellie
things calmed down quite a bit after
that much less ghosts
okay Georgie Lydia were married and now
lived in Franklin
okay Lily became pregnant Oh No the baby
was due on March in March 1801 but the
birth was difficult of both Lydia and
the baby died just as ghost Nellie
Butler had said they would after she
died George put olive Lydia's belongings
on a boat pushed it out in the water and
set it on fire
he's Viking funeral ever [ __ ] well this
probably meant that he thought there was
some sort of witchcraft devilry he
burned all her possessions so it
probably means he thought that
she was up to no good because why
because she died no because he might
have thought she was behind the ghost
[ __ ] like he okay okay right right but
how do you how does one over all this
time has passed so over time people are
more suspicious of lessons yeah yeah
clearly he became more suspicious right
but still gotta burn that [ __ ] okay
the bow is the hard thing to fake or
like do intentionally so the boat is
pulled out by the tides while it's
burning okay and it goes right past the
blaze Dale's farm Hey and the blaze
Dale's were really pissed that all of
Lydia's shits burning on a boat seems
dramatic they thought it was offensive
to her memory yeah yeah Abner would
forever hold a grudge against George oh
that's finally okay all right found the
line yep finally found something that
he's like that's crazy George married
again and had four kids he was a
traveling evangelist who had come oh
sorry there was there was the traveling
evangelist we had talked about before
he ended up coming and getting
eyewitness written accounts from people
okay he published all of them with
letters about the haunting in a book 37
letters dispositions in testimonies okay
in 1806 he was at home when two men said
there was a ghost wages no the other
evangelist so he's walking around the
two men come to his house and say the
hey there's a ghost in your field
hey so he looked out but all he saw was
a white rock and he decided it was
nonsense he wrote down when he saw quote
three minutes after I accidentally
looked in the same direction
and the white rock was in the air its
form a complete globe white and with a
tincture of red like the damask rose and
it's diameter about two feet Wow my eye
was constantly upon it I went on four or
five steps when it came to me from the
distance of eleven rods as quick as
lightning and instantly assumed a
personal form with a female dress
I went into the house and gave the
information not doubting that she had
come to spend some time with us as she
had before we went out to see her again
but to my great disappointment she had
vanished that was the last time anyone
ever reported seeing ghost Nellie Butler
could grudge Abner held against George
for burning Lydia's stuff would continue
for years George joined the first Church
in town of which Abner was a member but
at some point the church learned that
George had burned all of Lydia's things
and the church investigated it George
was then excommunicated from the church
okay some in the church were against
this and the church basically split in
half Jesus this is a divisive divisive
story the split lasted 17 years until
the church was finally dissolved the
reason was because so many disputes
broke out over the boat burnings
for 17 years the ghost of Nellie Butler
was seen in the day in the night in the
cellar in four houses including the
Millers house after the two-mile walk
along the two-mile walk in fields a
couple of times outside in fields she
was the first recorded and documented
ghost in American history and many
believe Nellie Butler's haunting led to
America being swept by spiritualism in
the 1800s but nobody knows what in the
[ __ ] happened what what nobody knows
what are you talking about nobody knows
how do I go to bed what here's what I
think I think that Lydia and her sister
okay concocted some [ __ ] way of
throwing their voices around probably
through tubes and then like you said a
reflection a lantern or the reflection
this is a time when people you know
there wasn't there's no [ __ ]
technology there's no scene good [ __ ] so
if you were able to use light in a way
but they're saying it takes on a female
form yeah I know and then I think that
there's just some people who just saw
thought they saw [ __ ] you know what four
was actually a ghost but as high as our
good that
is like everybody who talked to it
especially in August what was our
mission if it's okay if it was getting
married to Mary George what's up yeah I
think that I think that she went I think
that she made it seem like the ghost
came to Lydia and George to say you're
gonna die near so that it would it would
make people not think Lydia was behind
the ghost
so she's when she did stuff like that it
was like well that's kind of a threat to
me so people will not think it was me
but when the ghost came back in August
it was super [ __ ] chatty and like
totally normal and it was like talking
to a normal person it wasn't like
talking like no you've never heard a
story of someone just [ __ ] hanging on
talking about ghosts before I we need to
get close never will Aaron watch Lydia
drink a glass of water while I do it
it's truly the most insane ghost story
in American history because it's not
like there's some [ __ ] weird haunting
and people who mean possess it's just a
bunch of people [ __ ] hanging out and
talking about like every skeptic was
like it is no like they figured out how
to see rocks I just thought I just
wished that the final training I just
wished before they had died this sisters
had it would be the cool thing that said
right had said yeah we did this hey
we're the worst so yeah and maybe they
did in the family was like we can't tell
people oh my god do you believe in
ghosts now III mum for the most part I
always think teaming familiar demon
familiar yeah do you I know I don't I
mean I believe a lot of crazy [ __ ] right
and I don't doubt I'd yeah I'd honestly
go either way on ghosts I'm Pro you're
Pro ghost I'm Pro ghost I'm for them but
yeah I don't and I would say what if I
if you put a gun in my hands I do you
believe ago so I'd say yes go surreal
yeah see I don't think I'm that I I
don't I'm not there
I can't go on the ghost I believe in
aliens I believe crazy [ __ ] even oh yeah
anything aliens are out there that makes
more sense than Ellie why not say
Nellie's a real ghost but I'm saying
that aliens to me make a lot more sense
than it ghosts
what are we a tear Szold you've heard it
here first folks aliens make more sense
than a ghost and I'll knew why did they
film it oh man dude aliens make a lot
more sense it's a ghost I should be
handing you a blunt right now did hit
that I'll tell you why did but it's just
so it's also the religious aspect of
people are just like they want it to be
like any sign that it's real you know
the Jesus appearances yeah yeah they
want you want if you I mean what what is
what's different in that story is the
amount of skeptics that there are that
are sold in the way that it is actually
ends up being Nellie yeah
cuz normally it's like the people who
already believe will be like oh man the
Virgin Mary cried you know what's right
dumb [ __ ] is and people were coming
around I just think that they had
because because of the time they had to
have had something that made a
reflection that made everyone flip out
because people would not be used to that
like if you could or just taking a light
through a pinhole and making it appear
bigger or something like that your time
pinhole light yeah panel you cannot you
cannot totally it's a anyway you say it
and then my in my head I was like what
it was like a bag they put a lantern in
a bag like there were so many things I
was a bag lantern faction here to
present to you a theological is that of
that much or like I mean a lantern with
a sheet around is half day is Dave we
can Dave what are we doing well I
believe it to be mirrored star beam yeah
it's it's insane
Aaron do you believe in ghosts no ghosts
so I only only want to possibly see
where an aliens yes
and they just make more sense than goes
interesting yeah in losing more
something goes but I don't know you have
to compare them well because they're
both you know these sort of like
unproved now unprovable you know
otherworldly beings there I just don't
think it's like a ghost in an alien Chan
a lien would be an actual living
breathing like biological thing that
could exist out there I mean there's
clearly life on other planets somewhere
well there you go so you believe in
space ghosts I think we can meet in the
middle all right okay well we try to
have an honest ghost discussion all
right take care everybody do we have
anything that we want to say well join a
planet change and a PLA NIT changed 10
that's starting off and yeah like we
said we're gonna have a nice fluid dates
coming up so yep we'll let you know
Thanks